well it's a great question
a very fair question yes i think it's
very important i think this will
end up in the supreme court and i think
it's very important that we have nine
justices and i think the system is going
to go very quickly
i'll be submitting at five o'clock on
saturday the name of the
person i chose for this most important
of all positions
and i think we should go very quickly
you see the republicans are very united
as far as timing is concerned we were
elected
we have a lot of time one justice was
picked in 19 days
19 days we have we could do four at that
rate or five
that we have a lot of time no before the
election
and then you have after the election too
but in terms of time we go to january
20th
but i think it's better if you go before
the election because i think this
this scam that the democrats are pulling
it's a scam
the scam will be before the united
states supreme court
and i think having a 4-4 situation is
not a good situation
if you get that i don't know that you'd
get that i think it should be eight
nothing or nine nothing
but just in case it would be uh
more political than it should be i think
it's very important to have a uh
ninth chest are you fully confident that
lindsey graham can get this through the
committee and mitch mcconnell
i can only say we're giving you a person
whoever it would be i could say any of
the five frankly
five women are in the finalists and
uh they're all world-class brilliant
great
they're great in every respect from
academic everywhere
i think oh you can do it very easily you
can very quickly
from what i heard he doesn't even have
to hold a hearing he wouldn't have to
hold a hearing
he's going to i would think but but he
he wouldn't even actually have to hold
one
and you know most of these people are
young and they just went through the
process you know many of them just went
through the process
recently so it's not like gee let's look
at papers that are 15 years old
no i think the process is going to go
very quickly
uh the hearing i think lindsay's going
to call the data the hearing is soon you
can't call it until you have the can
today
and once we have the uh the nominee i
will
you know i i will wait to hear what the
date is but
from that point i would think would be
fairly quick they're all
extraordinary people i can't imagine it
could be anything else and
and the republicans i mean you saw them
as well as the republicans most of them
have
already made their intentions very clear
even josh so i think that uh
that's a tough vote right now so i think
i think we're in great shape but let me
ask you that question josh
john's asking a question about timing at
all
we have we have nothing but time yes
john i think i think absolutely we can't
get it done we could do it
even with a full complement of hearings
i think that you know the president just
deleted justice stevens was confirmed in
19 days justice ginsburg was confirmed
in about 40 days
uh we've got the time to do it we've got
the wherewithal to do it and um
i think we should have a vote for the
election for the reasons the president
articulates
and i think we can get it done and we
will mr president do you believe that
justice was served in the
rihanna taylor case in kentucky and what
is your message
to the black community who believe that
perhaps justice was not served
by the decision that was rendered by the
grand jury in kentucky well my message
is that i love the black community and
i've done more for the black community
than any other president
and i say uh with the possible exception
of abraham lincoln and i mean that with
zones and with criminal justice reform
with
prison reform with what we've done for
historically
black universities colleges schools what
we've done
it's nobody's done more abraham lincoln
let's give him the nod but beyond that
nobody's done more
i love the black community i don't know
enough about it i heard a decision was
just made
we've been together here and so we
haven't discussed it but after i see
what the decision is i will have a
comment on it okay thank you all very
much
thank you very much
[Music]
thank you thank you mr president
hey
okay thank you very much and we're here
today to discuss
protecting americans from censorship
cancel culture and consumer abuses
inflicted by big tech companies as
president
i'm committed to defending the freedom
of speech
and you know what's been going on and we
have some
very brilliant people in this room and
they've been looking at it for a while
we're joined by attorney general bill
barr senator josh hawley
state attorneys general ken paxton of
texas
mark brnovich of arizona jeff landry of
louisiana
lynn fitch of mississippi eric schmidt
of missouri alan wilson of south
carolina
sean reyes of utah leslie rutledge of
arkansas
and patrick morrissey of west virginia
that's a very talented group of people i
have to say
to have you all in one room we
appreciate it in recent years a small
group of powerful technology platforms
have tightened their grip over commerce
and communications
same time it allows iran supreme leader
to freely spew vile anti-semitic hate
and even death threats every year
countless americans are banned
blacklisted and silenced
through arbitrary or malicious
enforcement of ever-shifting rules
some platforms exploit their power
acquire vast sums of personal data
without consent
or rig their terms of service to coerce
mislead or defraud and we've seen it
so many times in may i directed attorney
general barr to work with the
state attorneys general as they enforce
the state laws against
deceptive business practices today's
discussion will focus on concrete legal
steps
to protect an open internet and a free
society
including steps to ensure the social
media companies cannot
deceive their users with hidden efforts
to manipulate
the spread of information
this is a very big subject we're going
to be discussing it we've been
discussing it
and over a fairly short period of time i
suspect we'll come to a conclusion i'd
like to ask
the attorney general to say a few words
bill please true
thank you mr president for convening
this round table
and it's a pleasure to have this
opportunity to
meet with all my colleagues at the state
attorneys general and
senator hawley and uh you state attorney
generals and i are meeting tomorrow
on some of our efforts uh in related
areas so i'm looking forward to that
meeting as well
but we're here today as part of the
president's executive order
on preventing online censorship
that order passed the department of
justice with a number of
responsibilities
first the department was directed by the
president to propose legislation to
reform section 230 of the communications
decency act
that's a provision that provides broad
civil immunity to online platforms both
for hosting
and for removing third-party content
i'm pleased to report that earlier today
the department on behalf
of the administration has sent to
congress proposed legislation to reform
section 230 and that legislation
addresses concerns about online
censorship
by requiring greater transparency and
accountability
when platforms remove lawful speech
your executive order also directed the
department to work with state attorneys
general to review how state laws can be
used
to combat deceptive and misleading
online
practices and i'd like to uh thank my
colleagues
from the states for joining us uh to
begin addressing this important topic
and i look forward to our broader
engagement on that issue
you know online platforms play a vital
role
in our society nearly everyone relies on
platforms now for
on a daily basis to communicate to share
private information buy goods receive
news and information
and we've grown to depend on it and
necessarily we have to put our trust
uh in these platforms but these
platforms can abuse
those positions of trust whether by
deciding
which voices they're going to amplify
and which they're going to throttle
and uh by improperly tracking and
collecting
uh user data and even facilitating
criminal activity
so the increased size and power of these
of these entities really exacerbates
those concerns and under the president's
leadership this administration is
committed
uh to addressing potential abuses of
online platforms
in a number of important ways i've
already mentioned that we have proposed
uh this legislation that will uh
focus uh the immunity and make sure it
is not
a license to abuse and to uh
censor their platforms uh
we also will provide the ability for
individuals to pursue civil claims
against online platforms that engage in
bad faith censorship
but even in its current form section 230
doesn't stop the states
whether we work whether they work alone
or together
or with the department of justice it
doesn't prevent the states
from using their own state laws against
platforms that are engaged in
defrauding or misleading users
section 230 does not bar the states from
bringing state law
causes of action based on the platform's
own conduct
as opposed to its role hosting
third-party conduct and when they engage
in unfair and deceptive practices state
ages can
be the tip of the spear so i'm looking
forward to working with all of you
i know some states have already brought
some interesting cases
against platforms for fraud deception
and misuse of
uh sensitive personal data and we think
there's
ample opportunity to continue those
investigations and actions and i'm
looking forward to working with all of
you
to address that thank you mr president
thank you very much bill
josh please well uh thank you mr
president
for convening this roundtable it's good
to see my former colleagues of course i
used to be a state attorney general so
great to see all of you again thanks for
the tremendous work you're doing thank
you
that's right that's right until until
somebody at this table convinced me to
run for something else but uh i think
that just to amplify the president's
remarks
uh we are we see in these online
platforms the most powerful
corporations in the world maybe the most
powerful corporations in the history of
the world they've got more information
on americans than any companies have
ever had any government has ever had
they increasingly control our
communication with each other
how come i won last time because you
beat them at their own game
you were so good at communicating but uh
and as you know
it's gotten by the way it's kind of a
lot of time it's gotten a lot worse and
as these folks
should know reporters know because these
online platforms increasingly control
the flow of news
uh from uh journalists to the american
public so these are incredibly powerful
platforms
they need to be held accountable and uh
section 230 reforming six and two thirty
is vital part of that
thank you george been a big factor would
anybody like to say anything
anybody in particular sure mr president
thank you again for convening
attorney general i appreciate the work
we're doing
in this investigation of google you know
one of the reasons that we were so
interested in this is really what you
said
senator hall is that you know we're at
this point where we have these
corporations that
have tremendous power and if we don't
step up to the point now and take a look
at what they're doing how they're doing
it
we may never stop it it may be just
unstoppable some of them are
they're really larger than countries and
more powerful than countries
and they know more about people than we
know about ourselves which is a little
scary so
i i i appreciate the attorney generals
that are working on our case now and
that
are going forward with other issues and
i think this relationship that we've had
with
with the department of justice under you
has been just amazing and i'm really
appreciative of it because i think
together
and it takes us together to take on some
of the forces that we're dealing with so
thank you very much
thank you well i think we can say that
we're watching them very closely during
this
election cycle they're being watched and
scrutinized very very closely by
everybody at this table and
far beyond this table a lot of people
are watching and we're going to just see
we see so many things that are unfair
but
this is big time and
we'll let you know we're gonna let you
know but it's uh it's
very serious very bad very serious uh
lynn would you like to say something
thank you mr president thank you general
barbara we appreciate it's an
opportunity for us to all come together
and work and
hope these big tech companies
accountable this is an opportunity where
they've been censoring our freedom of
voices
and americans just not going to stand
for that and so i appreciate the
opportunity for us to all work together
to move forward with
changing of 230 and change the dynamics
of expression for
voices thank you lynn very much anybody
else anybody
go ahead please mr president uh i have a
story that i think you'll enjoy
when you were being criticized by
twitter related to absentee ballots that
very same day
we concluded an investigation in west
virginia which affirmed a lot of the
very things
you were saying so that type of issue is
an example of what can happen when you
have these social media companies run
them up
and there needs to be accountability
there needs to be an advancement in the
first amendment but
i thought you'd appreciate the iron of
that very day that person's going to go
to jail
now and meanwhile twitter continues to
engage
and pretend that what's true is not the
whole thing with your
balloting and what's going on with
balloting will prove to be one of the
great catastrophes
in the history of our country even
beyond elections
and the democrats know it they know
what's going on they know how it's going
on
who's getting it who's sending it where
is it going where is it coming back
where is it coming from
are mailman involved who's delivering it
it's a very very uh and they know it's
going to be
and all you have to do is look at as in
a case in west virginia but many cases
i would say every single case in the
last number of years
where they've done this and this is a
tiny scale
compared to millions and millions of
ballots that are being sent
this is going to be one of the great
catastrophes and one of the great
embarrassments
in the history of our country beyond
elections
and the democrats know it and they're
setting it up for chaos
and that's what they've done and these
media companies if you criticize it
they flag you they take you down they do
all sorts of things
and they know it too they know it too
but you've done a great job when you did
that in west virginia and it was
it happened to be the same day that we
were criticized
for just mentioning you better be
careful with
unsolicited balance see i think that's a
better name josh
because they said universal ballots and
that 15 different names didn't mean
people said how does that have to do
with
being universal unsolicited
80 million unsolicited ballots being
sent
all over the place people are going to
get them what the hell is this
what is it they'll be harvesting them
like crazy
in i mean some of the states
they have no signature necessary no
verification necessary
nevada you don't have to verify the
signature
there's no verification it is a disgrace
that this can happen just remember
i told you so i told you so
we're gonna win anyway i hope but i'll
tell you it's very tough when you have
uh
democrat i mean it's democrat governors
it's states controlled by democrat
governors
and they're sending them out by the
millions and
josh it's going to be a mess and they
all know it and the people that know it
the most of the democrats they fully
know
and then they talk about your
suppressing our right to vote
they're using covid as a way of scamming
the system and when you talk about
foreign countries
foreign countries are nothing compared
to what's taking place
and if foreign countries want to this is
an easy system
to break into it because they'll do
counterfeit ballots
they'll do counterfeit ballots by the
millions
so when you talk about china russia
north korea iran all the countries you
talk about
that's peanuts that's all peanuts
compared to this but this
is their opening because they can use
nice
cheap ballots and they can send them out
counterfeit them and just send them in
this is a disaster and they should stop
it before it's too late now where before
numerous federal judges
from what i hear great federal judges
and they have the power to stop it
i hope they're watching because
somebody's got to make the plea
this is going to be a disaster i'm not
even saying bad for me
you could work both ways i don't think
it will work both ways but it could work
both ways could be against
republicans or democrats but
i hope somebody's watching because this
is a disaster waiting to happen
thank you all very
to have much full complement of the
supreme court well it's a great question
a very fair question yes i think it's
very important i think this will
end up in the supreme court and i think
it's very important that we have nine
justices and i think the system's going
to go very quickly
i'll be submitting at five o'clock on
saturday the name of the
person i chose for this most important
of all positions
and uh i think we should go very quickly
you see the republicans are very united
as far as timing is concerned we were
elected
we have a lot of time one justice was
picked in 19 days
19 days we have we could do four at that
rate or five
now we have a lot of time no before the
election
and then you have after the election too
but in terms of time we go to january
20th
but i think it's better if you go before
the election because i think this
this scam that the democrats are pulling
it's a scam
the scam will be before the united
states supreme court
and i think having a 4-4 situation is
not a good situation
if you get that i don't know that you'd
get that i think it should be eight
nothing or nine-nothing
but just in case it would be uh
more political than it should be i think
it's very important to have a
ninth chest are you fully confident that
lindsey graham can get this through the
committee
i can only say we're giving you a person
whoever it would be i could say any of
the five frankly with
five women are in the finalists and
uh they're all world-class brilliant
great
they're great in every respect from
academic everywhere
i thought oh he can do it very easily he
can very quickly
from what i heard he doesn't even have
to hold a hearing he wouldn't have to
hold a hearing
he's going to i would think but but he
he wouldn't even actually have to hold
one
and you know most of these people are
young and they just went through the
process you know many of them just went
through the process
recently so it's not like gee let's look
at papers that are 15 years old
no i think the process is going to go
very quickly
uh the hearing i think lindsey is going
to call the data the hearing is soon you
can't call it until you have the
candidate
and once we have the uh the nominee i
will
you know i i will wait to hear what the
date is but
from that point i would think would be
fairly quick they're all
extraordinary people i can't imagine it
could be anything else and
and the republicans i mean you saw him
as well as the republicans most of them
have
already made their intentions very clear
even josh so i think that uh
that's a tough vote right now so i think
i think we're in great shape but let me
ask you that question josh
john's asking a question about timing
and all
we have we have nothing but time john i
think i think absolutely we can't get it
done we could do it
even with a full complement of hearings
i think that you know the president has
deluded justice stevens was confirmed in
19 days justice ginsburg was confirmed
in about 40 days
we've got the time to do it we've got
the wherewithal to do it and
i think we should have a vote before the
election for the reasons the president
articulates
and i think we can get it done and we
will mr president do you believe that
justice was served in the
rihanna taylor case in kentucky and what
is your message
to the black community who believe that
perhaps justice was not served
by the decision that was rendered by the
grand jury in kentucky well my message
is that i love the black community and
i've done more for the black
community than any other president and i
say
with the possible exception of abraham
lincoln and i mean that with
opportunity zones and with criminal
justice reform with
prison reform with what we've done for
historically
black universities colleges schools what
we've done
it's nobody's done more abraham lincoln
let's give him the nod but beyond that
nobody's done more
i love the black community i don't know
enough about it i heard a decision was
just made
we've been together here and so we
haven't discussed it but after
i see what the decision is i will have a
comment on it okay
thank you all very much thank you very
much
[Music]
thank you thank you mr president
thank you
you